s'il est mal sorti mercredi sur les
écrans français du film de lars von
trier dancer in the dark
l'histoire se déroule dans les années 60
c'est la chanteuse islandaise bjork qui
joue le rôle principal
son ami son aide est interprétée par
catherine deneuve soir le film de la
rentrée ce fut le grand vainqueur du
dernier festival de cannes palme d'or
prix d'interprétation pour bjork
présentation marie-jo juin et nathalie
gallet
flash back sur une palme d'or annonce
est un pur moment d'émotion au festival
de cannes 2000 la projection de dancer
in the dark viennent de se terminer
le public est debout lars von triers et
déjà qu'il a gagné son pari réussir sa
première comédie musicale un rêve
d'enfant qui l'a situé dans l'amérique
des années 60
c'est l'histoire de scellement ouvrière
qui se réfugie dans sa passion pour la
musique
la jeune femme porte un lourd secret
elle perd la vue et son fils connaîtra
le même sort s'il ne trouve pas l'argent
pour le faire opérer à ses côtés sa
meilleure amie katy catherine deneuve
comme un ange gardien râleur par dessus
la tête c'est fais ce que tu veux pas il
coupe tout à une main je travaille la
nuit si tu veux mais débrouille toi tout
seul ne compte surtout pas sur moi pour
dire à tous coups elle était très
protectrice et quand on lui demandait
son avis ils ont répondu qu'ils auraient
peut-être pas fait comme ça mais vas-y
ma fille feltesse cao cao un prix
d'interprétation pour bjork un second
rôle pour catherine deneuve
c'est elle qui a écrit à lars von trier
pour lui demander un rôle il en a créé
spécialement pour elle
un peu
oui
dung
il y avait cinq actrices dans le monde
du cinéma avec qui j'avais toujours rêvé
de tout gratuit et catherine était l'une
d'elles vraiment et c'est un rêve devenu
réalité cette date the dream comme ceux
ci avec ce premier rôle bjork a beaucoup
appris
catherine deneuve elle n'a pas eu peur
de prendre des risques elle a été très
courageuse d'improviser comme ça pour le
film ce qu'elle n'avait jamais fait
c'était étonnant
et quand on lui demande si ce monument
de cinéma fera date dans sa filmographie
catherine répond que la curiosité du
film c'est avant tout bjork